actually my frustration at animating
Tony Tony the bell tree is partly
responsible for the dinosaurs in
Jurassic Park yes I'll prove it do tell
do tell so when a new item when you I
was animating Tony I was animating okay
it's harder it's harder with one hand so
I would animate and then ah here you go
perfect so I would animate and then we
would decide you know Tony's tool is
leaning too much for put let's put him
backwards oh [ __ ] put the hands back
okay he's too backwards oh [ __ ] let's
put him back so Daniel agua was one of
the co-directors he was going that's
there's got to be a better way to do
this so he wrote a software after Tony
came out and unlocked the hands on the
keyboard that process is called inverse
kinematics with two guys he went in his
basement and wrote what became Softimage
in 1991 this year he showed at siggraph
the demo of Softimage with inverse
kinematics on two characters and it blew
everyone away the island people were
there they bought a bunch of licenses
and use Softimage to animate the doctors
and that's why the dinosaurs that's why
the dinosaurs actually are able to walk
all right very cool
you